in the last video we saw a reality where
the currency between or the exchange
rate between the wand and the dollar
started off at ten to one and at that
exchange rate at that exchange rate
China was shipping more goods in terms
of whether you measured it in dollars or
Juan was shipping more to the US than
the US was shipping to China and because
of that we saw an imbalance in the
currencies the wand became more
expensive or the dollar became cheaper
until eventually Chinese goods got
expensive enough that there was less
demand in the US and US Goods got cheap
enough that there was more demand in
China that the trade actually came into
balance now what that's okay if everyone
wants to wanted to have balance trade
but what if the Chinese government
didn't want it that they said hey we
needed to develop the United States has
already developed we want to have an
industrial base we want to have a market
to sell our goods to we want to export
more to the United States than we import
from them we want export led growth so
they don't like the dynamic that they
saw they didn't like the currency they
did not like the one getting expensive
so let's say the Chinese government let
me scroll up a little bit so the Chinese
the Chinese government government wants
wants to keep currency currency exchange
exchange pegged pegged pegged at I ran
out of space over there they want to
keep currency exchange pegged at 10:1
per dollar and they want that because
they want this situation to keep on
going forever the China keeps shipping
more of the US than the US ships to
China or maybe they'll even they even
wanted to go even more that China keeps
shipping more and more to the US than
the US shipped to China so that China
could build its industrial base and I
guess a more sinister view is also so
that the United States is industrial
base gets depleted that they keep
manufacturing things cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper
the united states manufacturers can't
compete and we'll talk about this in
more videos it's not it's not it's it's
actually not clear that it's a hundred
percent one-sided that there's actually
some benefits of the United States also
gets from this and we'll discuss that
more it's a little bit more involved so
how could they do this let's just say
that the Chinese government wants this
reality and they want this reality
frozen they do not want the reality
where the trade bounces how could they
intervene in currency markets so that
this doesn't change because as we said
if more Chinese goods are being bought
there is more demand for wan the wan
should appreciate the dollar should go
down but how do you get both how do you
have your cake and eat it too how do you
get more goods being shipped to the
United States then back to China without
the one appreciating and the way you do
that there the Chinese government or
maybe in particular we could talk about
the such Chinese central bank the
Chinese central bank which is a part of
the Chinese government can say hey to
keep our wan devalued we will print
money so let me draw the Chinese central
bank so the central bank of China so
what the central bank of China let me
intervene over here the central bank of
China so let me do this in a new color
so right over here we have the Chinese
the Chinese central central the Chinese
central bank and what they do they can
actually just print money so we had this
a generic scenario that I had outlined
in the last two videos where we had this
imbalance there was demand for a
thousand one but only supply of five
hundred one so what they can do is just
equalize this they could just print they
could just print five hundred one so
they literally could just print 501 501
and then try to convert that into
dollars and then try or they will
convert that into dollars convert it in
to dollars so what just happened now all
of a sudden we
have $100 that are trying to be
converted into roughly a thousand wons
or if that exchange rate were to be
constant so there's demand for a
thousand ones before the Chinese central
bank got involved there was only a 501
supply but now the Chinese central bank
says okay there's a demand for a
thousand one there's only 500 Wan supply
we're gonna produce another 500 Wan we
literally can just print it and then
they will convert what they printed in
two dollars so just like that you now
have a balance of supply and demand you
have a thousand one 500 here and 500
here that want to be converted into
dollars and then you have a hundred
dollars that want to be converted into I
guess a thousand one so if they were to
do this the currency wouldn't change the
supply and then or the exchange rate
wouldn't exchange the supply and demand
of the two currencies would be equal now
there's and that would work and frankly
that's what they have been doing for
some time now but there's one kind of
catch here the whole time that they're
doing this what is happening what is
happening well they keep shipping more
to the United States than the United
States is shipping to China these guys
keep having to print one and buy dollars
with those wan in order to keep the
Chinese currency cheap so these people
are going to keep accumulating dollars
they just keep printing one and then
they just keep accumulating dollars so
let me draw that over here so the
Chinese central bank just starts
accumulating many many dollars they can
they can print one as much as they want
those wan go into the they've trade them
into dollars and then they start these
guys start accumulating these guys just
start accumulating more and more dollars
over here and the more that they want
this trade and balance to occur the
longer that they wanted to occur the
more dollars that they will have to
accumulate so they have to just keep on
doing it they can't even stop doing it
have to keep doing it in order to keep
the trade balance the way it is in the
next video I'll talk about what they
actually have to do with these dollars
because they actually won't just keep it
in cash what they actually have to do
with these dollars and then what effect
that actually might have on the United
States economy and then we could talk
about how
this might unwound unwind itself but
we'll find out it's actually very
difficult for all of this for the
scenario to unwind once it gets started